today on campaign check anti-semitism in
the Labour Party central to this issue
allegations labor isn't dealing with
complaints quickly or seriously the
chief rabbi fr I am nervous said that
claims that the party is doing
everything it reasonably can to tackle
anti-jewish racism and that it's
investigated every single case our
mendacious fiction rabbi Mervis cites
figures from the jewish labor movement
that there are at least 130 outstanding
anti-semitism cases at a high level
labour says these figures are wrong but
it hasn't released any counter data so
what do we know Labour's most recent
figures from January to June this year
suggest that they received complaints of
anti-semitism against 625 labour party
members some are still being processed
some have been dismissed but they say
that 97 members have been referred to
its highest level
disciplinary body the National
constitutional Committee 28 of those
cases were concluded with 8 expulsion
so that leaves 69 unresolved cases by
their own figures but that only covers a
six month period so we don't know how
many remain unresolved from the year
before or the number of new cases the
Jewish labor movement told Sky News the
party does know the figure and it's over
130 labour says it won't offer a running
commentary but today's critics thinks
that's part of the problem the Board of
Deputies has described the process as an
OPEC and factional disciplinary process
labor stresses that complaints where the
parties rules on anti-semitism were
breached account for just not 0.1% of
the party's membership and it's right
that anti-semitism is not just an issue
for labour it's a growing problem up and
down the country the Home Office figures
show that there were 672 hate crimes
targeting Jewish people in 2017-18 and
that number doubled to over 1300 the
following year while stats from the
Community Safety Trust which records
anti-semitic incidents show a clear rise
to a record high last year although the
charity says in more recent years
there's been more awareness and
reporting when it comes to labor the
party has not been able to back up its
claim that every case has been
investigated but nor is there a full
picture to back up the chief rabbis
claim that they're not doing enough
no more when the equalities watchdog
investigation into labor comes back
sometime after the election